I suffer with migraines you can kind of
see my issues I've got Tick Tock star
Jahan Thomas has died she was 30 years
old her death was announced in a
GoFundMe page set up by a friend who
calls her death unexpected even after
she documented health issues on social
media good afternoon to talk
um I thought I would do a bit of an
update over the past several months
Jehan a mother of two suffered from
painful migraines
as you can see
I have one of my Prussia migraines back
I can't lose my head and it feels like
my head is going to fall off in one of
her final posts she says she was
awaiting surgery and that her pain had
left her unable to walk I've just called
my neurologist's office for advice and
they said that I should go back to the
hospital but I'm physically cannot lay
in that bed any longer
try my hardest to not show my kids this
when these headaches completely wipe me
off my face
and obviously I'm at home with them
hard not to show them donations from the
GoFundMe page will go to the star's two
sons Isaac and Elijah
[Music]